-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden said today
that he is planning to name
his nominee to replace
retiring Supreme Court
Justice Stephen Breyer
by the end of next month
and then,
a day or two after that,
he'll nickname the nominee.
[ As Biden ]
Hey, Super Judge!
[ Laughter ]
Judge-arino.
I'll get one. Don't worry.
[ Laughter ]
After White House
Press Secretary Jen Psaki
said yesterday
that President Biden
will stand by his commitment
to appoint a Black woman
to the Supreme Court,
a Fox News panel criticized
the administration's
selection process.
I'll take a wild guess and say
they have exactly two problems
with a Black woman.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The pharmaceutical company
Moderna announced yesterday
that it has begun testing
its Omicron-specific
coronavirus vaccine.
Feels like that might be
outdated by the time it's ready.
That's like hearing that Apple's
working on an iPhone 7.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the U.S. economy last quarter
grew by 6.9%.
"My pleasure!"
said Spider-Man.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
According to a new report,
a witness told
federal prosecutors
that he was present
when Republican
Congressman Matt Gaetz
was told
that he had sex with a minor
and he said you could've heard
a pin drop
at that Homecoming dance.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
And almost in here.
[ Laughter ]
In honor of the park's
30th anniversary
and Women's History Month
in March,
Disneyland Paris
announced yesterday
that Minnie Mouse will wear
a dark blue-and-black
polka-dotted pantsuit
designed by Stella McCartney.
Unfortunately, that still won't
make up for the fact
that you brought your wife
to Paris
and then took her to Disneyland.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Hey, did you see the pantsuit?
Uh-huh."
[ Laughter ]
A representative of the
anti-drug group D.A.R.E.
criticized the HBO show
"Euphoria" in a new interview
and said it glorifies narcotics
use among high school students.
But, realistically,
how many teens can afford
HBO and narcotics?
[ Laughter and applause ]
McDonald's is set to begin
selling a new item,
consisting
of a chicken sandwich,
Big Mac, and Filet-O-Fish
all in one bun,
called Land, Air & Sea,
as opposed to its original name,
Bathroom, Hospital, Cemetery.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Indistinct ]
And, finally,
the Navy announced yesterday
that it has discharged
45 sailors
for refusing to get
the coronavirus vaccine.
Wow, I didn't realize the virus
could be transmitted
through seamen.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
Discharged.
Discharged seamen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that was the show
for the whole night?
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue.